let me take you back to july 16
1945. on this day a team of nuclear
engineers detonated the world's first
nuclear device ever
right here in new mexico it's hard to
overstate this moment this moment ended
an era and started a new one
21 days later a u.s bomber flew over a
city in southern japan with one of these
bombs in its belly and it dropped it
from 30 000 feet above the ground the
bomb dropped for 43 seconds before
exploding a few hundred meters above the
ground turning this city into dust
this was the first time that a nuclear
weapon had ever been used to kill humans
and three days later the us dropped
another one on another city in japan 360
000 people most of them civilians dead
from these attacks the president at the
time harry truman was on a ship crossing
the atlantic from europe his voice
broadcasting across the world an
american airplane
dropped one bomb on hiroshima that bomb
has more power than 20 000 tons of tnt
[Music]
the nuclear era had begun and soon the
soviet union was developing a bomb of
their own it became a race who could
develop the biggest and best bomb but
this nuclear bomb technology was
unpredictable and not really well
understood the only way to keep
developing it was to test it so that
they could understand how to build these
things the first test was here in the
u.s but soon the tests moved far away
from the u.s deep into the pacific
this is the story of a bomb but it's
also the story of the cultural shock
waves that these faraway tests created
here in the u.s and around the world
from french swimsuits to propaganda
films meant to deceive the nation to
monsters and japanese protest films this
story has some twists and turns so
buckle up and let me tell you the story
of why the u.s bombed the out of these
islands
the bomb will not start a chain reaction
in the water converting it all to gas
letting all the ships on all the oceans
drop down to the bottom we have spent
more than 2 billion
on the greatest scientific gamble in
history
and we have won
one second let's just take a quick pause
to talk about today's sponsor who is
policy genius thank you policy genius
for sponsoring this video i always
thought life insurance was something i
had to think about when i got a lot
older
but with a little bit of research i
realized that having life insurance now
is a much smarter and cheaper thing to
do if you have anyone who depends on
your income it is very smart to get life
insurance and policy genius is a really
easy way to compare different policies
and pick one that fits your life i've
just recently signed up for policy
genius to get a quote on life insurance
and it's a really easy process you go
through a very simple questionnaire that
is not complicated very approachable
very easy it took me a few minutes
really and then a representative at
policy genius handles all of the
paperwork and all the complicated stuff
so that you just have to answer the
questions that pertain to you and your
life they do the rest the license expert
at policy genius works for you not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and buying process policy
genius makes it easy to compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all in
one place you can save fifty percent or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius you could save
thirteen hundred dollars or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies one of the
things i learned in my research is that
life insurance is a lot cheaper the
younger you are so getting locked into a
plan while you're young is not only
prudent and wise but also
saves you money policy genius is a
fantastic way to get started with that
there are no extra fees they don't sell
your data to anybody it is just a place
to go compare quotes from a bunch of
different insurers and pick a policy
that's right for you so go to
policygenius.com johnny harris link is
also in the description
to get started right away thank you
again policy genius for supporting this
channel and now back to our story
[Music]
okay let's back up and talk about that
very first nuclear test in new mexico
this is the bomb that they use they blew
this thing up in the most remote place
they could find in the u.s 100 miles
south of albuquerque in the middle of
the new mexican desert because this was
the first nuke ever no one really knew
what was gonna happen they had no idea
how explosive this thing was and so this
guy who ran the test range his name was
norris bradbury he was in charge of like
measuring this like assessing how big
the blast was so he could report and be
like these nuclear bombs are this
powerful he was not ready for what he
saw next
after the explosion he said verbatim
quote the atom bomb did not fit into any
preconceptions possessed by anybody i.e
you can't fathom how insanely powerful
this thing is you could see the flash
and feel the shock wave from 160 miles
away it was clear that this bomb was
unpredictable and hard to measure and
scientists were realizing that the
radiation from this bomb could spread
and they didn't know how much and how
far and how dangerous this thing would
be the director of the project of the
nuclear weapon sort of freaked out with
the lack of precision on all of this
he's like did we just poison the entire
southwestern united states with
radiation
so they realized that they had to find a
more remote place if they were going to
keep testing their nukes and so this is
where the treasure hunt for the perfect
nuclear testing site begins it is the
duty of the military services to explore
the military might of this new weapon so
you get these two naval officers who are
tasked with like finding the next
nuclear test site and they literally
just said quote we just took out a dozen
maps and started looking for remote
sites okay i can get on board with just
pulling out a bunch of maps and just
like perusing around sort of what i do
in my spare time so i can totally see
this happening as they were looking at
these maps they quickly realized that
nowhere in the us is like a good fit for
a nuclear test site they needed
somewhere that was extremely far away
from population centers and they needed
it to be not like freezing cold like in
alaska or something i'm just imagining
harry truman the president at the time
in the course of 30 days this guy just
tested this new
bonkers technology which happened to put
an entire city at risk he literally
destroyed two japanese cities and won
the war with this technology from like a
global control and leadership
perspective this guy is feeling very
powerful
except for he's a little bit nervous
about the intel that the ussr is working
on the same weapon they've been doing it
for three years and the world is
generally in a state of uncertainty
empires that ruled for centuries are
losing control there's now two
governments that are competing for
global dominance and these weapons these
nuclear weapons are the key to winning
and now truman is being told that you
can't test these weapons on american
soil because they're too close to
population centers so what do you do so
truman decides that if the perfect
nuclear test site doesn't exist he will
make it exist so back to these maps
where do we go where do we set up the
test site they start looking far far
away off of u.s soil deep into the ocean
and they eventually settled on this
little strip of beach called the bikini
atoll this is bikini it is here that the
military and scientific personnel
conduct the tests with the atomic bomb
the name bikini means coconut island
roughly in the local language they liked
this island because the weather was good
there wasn't a lot of storms and it had
this nice lagoon that they could
position a naval fleet there to see what
nuclear weapons do to naval vessels
these islands had sort of been conquered
by japan but then the u.s obviously
conquered japan so they sort of took
over these islands but they didn't
officially own them but they wanted to
the problem was that there was a bunch
of people living on these islands oh and
by the way this isn't 1893 you can't
just show up and steal islands anymore
without people getting sort of pissed
off so harry truman what do you do you
send in this guy mr ben wyatt thank you
thanks the guy's name was ben wyatt no
no no not not that one it's a different
one from like the 40s
and he is on a mission to obtain this
atoll from the locals so that the u.s
can turn it into their nuclear
playground one of the secret reasons why
the u.s picked this island wasn't just
because of the weather and the lagoon it
was also because these people had
already been visited by christian
missionaries they were used to white
people arriving to their country and
trying to convince them of things and
this became
really useful so one sunday after church
he gathers all the local bikinians to
ask them if they would like to leave
their island and he promises them this
will be temporary we just need it for a
little bit people are like oh okay but
don't worry ben is prepared for this
he's got something in his back pocket he
starts to compare the bikinians to the
children of israel the chosen people
saying that this is their duty to leave
the islands so that the u.s can pursue
their noble aim of testing nuclear
weapons the united states government now
wants to turn this great destructive
power
into something for the benefit of
mankind he's just buttering them up with
jesus and it is so blatant and
everything being in god's hands it must
be good so eventually we're not really
sure how it all went down with whatever
back room deals but under the condition
that these people would be able to come
back they agreed to leave the island to
hand them over to the us but wait don't
go yet says ben wyatt after the deal is
made he invites a film crew from
national geographic to stage a
reenactment of the whole scenario to
make a film for a month crossroads scene
25 take one
they had these like shoots in the
churches that they had to have the
people there like go to church several
times so that they could get it from
different angles
[Music]
glory to god in the highest
[Music]
they made this huge propaganda film and
guess who it was for the american people
it was like look united states yes we're
taking over this island but look at how
happy these people are they love this
look at how cool ben wyatt is with his
like charismatic convincing persuasive
jesus talk so the us is one step closer
to having their nuclear playground they
ship away these natives to nearby
islands with no food water or shelter
[Music]
and then the bombs begin
[Music]
they dropped their first nuke on the
bikini atoll on june 30th 1946. these
were much bigger bombs than were dropped
in japan and unlike the original tests
which were very secret the us now wanted
the world or the soviet union to know
about it it was like a giant pr campaign
the opposite of top secret a radio
station will be broadcasting from bikini
and it totally worked soon the whole
world was like what the u.s is like
testing atomic bombs on a random atoll
in the middle of the pacific a few days
after this first test on bikini a french
fashion designer released his new
swimsuit it was a two-piece women's
swimsuit that wait for it revealed a
woman's belly button
highly scandalous there was a ton of
outcry it was highly controversial and
when he announced it he saw an
opportunity to ride this publicity wave
happening from the nuclear test so he
named the swimsuit the bikini
[Music]
it was radical it was scandalous it was
controversial but it totally worked the
question
should a bikini is abandoned
he and his swimsuit got tons of
attention both good and bad do you think
that bikinis should be banned well i
most certainly do oh definitely not no
rather than wear a bikini why we're
ending at
but the naming of the bikini is just the
beginning of how these nuclear bombs
started shaping and influencing popular
culture
children's toys comics cartoons
superheroes alcoholic drinks beauty
pageants songs the word atomic was
everywhere people started saying you're
the bomb as a compliment people calling
someone atomic now meant you're hot and
all the while the tests on bikini got
bigger and more frequent way way bigger
than anything that happened in japan you
know that bomb that killed over 350 000
people yeah these bombs were way bigger
and people started to get scared so much
so that the commander for these bikini
tests had to get up in front of the
nation and dispel some of these fears
like whether or not the bomb would blow
up the whole ocean the bomb will not
start a chain reaction in the water or
whether or not it would turn the ocean
into gas converting it all to gas and
letting all the ships on all the oceans
drop down to the bottom or one of the
leading theories was that this bomb was
so intense it would crack open the earth
and the core would leak out and it would
be the end of gravity it will not blow
out the bottom of the sea and let all
the water run down the hole
it will not destroy gravity
i am not an atomic playboy wait what
what did he just say
i am not an atomic playboy
oh my gosh
i can't
so it turns out this guy was in love
with what was happening on bikini he was
just like so into this and after the
first test he staged a giant celebration
in which a literal nuke shaped cake was
produced and it turns out that some
people didn't like the fact that this
guy was celebrating like the advent of
this destructive weapon especially
surrounded by women quote dressed to the
nines and so because of all of this
partying and the cake and whatever he
was dubbed the atomic playboy which is
just an amazing title i am not an atomic
playboy okay but there's one more very
important way that these nuclear tests
on bikini influenced our culture and
it's not swimsuits and it's not even
spongebob who lives in bikini bottom and
occasionally has a run-in with nukes
it's what happened in february 1954
when they tested this guy a particularly
huge bomb a thousand times larger than
hiroshima when this bomb was detonated
at bikini a japanese tuna fishing boat
named lucky dragon was nearby i mean it
wasn't nearby but for this bomb it was
in range it received a large dose of
radiation and the crew of 23 men
returned to japan where they were
hospitalized it was reported that some
of the tuna from their boat was sold and
consumed by japanese citizens the ship's
cargo of tani fish was found to be
radioactive and had to be buried in the
ground you have to understand radiation
is a freaky thing it is this invisible
force that destroys your cells without
you ever seeing or feeling anything at
first this panic spread and japan's
fishing economy took a giant hit
japanese citizens were horrified
throughout the towns and villages of
japan the people young and old are
adding their signatures to this appeal
stop the experiments outlaw the bomb
and one activist created a protest film
which took place on an island that has a
very similar resemblance to bikini
and then near this island a monster
named gojira is born he comes out of the
ocean quote emitting high levels of
h-bomb radiation are you getting where
we're going here the first thing that
the monster does after emerging was
destroying a tuna boat labeled lucky
dragon i mean this is totally on the
nose it's not like a hidden symbolism
film this film was a pointed protest at
all of these tests and the effects that
they were having on the local people
ecology and economies and it helped
mobilize a fierce anti-nuclear movement
in japan that was already there because
of what japan had already experienced
[Music]
oh and the film was actually pretty good
so the film actually came to the us too
it was dubbed over in english for us
audiences but it was renamed to godzilla
and it was edited to remove all of the
overt anti-nuclear symbols the
government's like we can't have that
happening we're putting so much work
into the pr of projecting how good
nuclear weapons are no way some protest
film from japan about a monster is going
to derail this so godzilla
lost its protest appeal and became just
another monster movie dynamic violence
savage action
spectacular thrill in the years
following world war ii
this is the total amount of explosive
force detonated between the u.s and the
soviet union but when broken down by
location you can see that 87 of this
explosive force took place right here so
many bombs were dropped here including
one named castle bravo which was
literally a thousand times more powerful
than the one dropped on hiroshima
there's no way we can fathom this really
but we can sort of try to do a thought
exercise to understand how powerful
these bombs are if you detonated this
here in washington dc 90 of the
population of dc and baltimore and
philadelphia and new york
would disappear in just three days okay
so unsurprisingly back in bikini the
locals never got to go back that was
never the intention it was all a lie as
much of a lie as the propaganda film
itself even if they did go back it would
be a death sentence a recent study found
that this group of islands is more
radioactive than the chernobyl exclusion
zone but guess what no one cared no one
cares when told about this radioactivity
in the pacific secretary of state henry
kissinger said and i quote there are
only 90 000 of them out there who gives
a damn one [ __ ] so this story
explains how we got the name for the
swimsuit the bikini why spongebob lives
where he lives and why we use the word
bomb as a compliment but it also teaches
us a deeper lesson about what lengths we
will go to retain power or as some frame
it to maintain peace that's a
complicated paradox to entangle
especially when this piece that we're
talking about relies on the potential of
absolute destruction the race to build
and test these nuclear weapons led to
the u.s not taking the risk on their own
soil instead doing what we've done so
expertly for many many decades exporting
that risk and those consequences to
faraway places to places where we can
manipulate and lie to the people and
then pollute their oceans forever